the global Elites the government
whatever you want to call them they need
men to be weak fat and compliant because
when men are weak fat and complying
they're easier to control and how are
they doing this by feminizing them by
telling them it's okay to be emotional
by telling them to share their feelings
but that's just not going to get you
anywhere in life that's not how a man
should be a man should be strong the
woman should be able to lean on a man he
should be able to provide and protect
for her so that she can then raise the
Next Generation and be nurturing whereas
he can then go out and conquer the world
and look after and protect her and so
when he is feminized the government can
then come in and take control of the
family there's no leadership anymore the
husband are supposed to lead the woman
and the children in the correct
direction but if there's no leadership
there's a vacuum for the government to
come in and tell the family what to do